[Music]
really
well contestant Shawn pues wasn't the
only one who fell in love with Kaitlyn
Bristowe on The Bachelorette we all did
but there is a lot that Kaitlyn has
never revealed about what it was like to
be on the show and she is finally
dropping those bombshell with 80 on
lines lauren zima looking back is there
anything you would have done differently
from that time no I mean it's kind of a
blur to be honest with you it's unlike
any other situation you'll ever be in in
your life
I lost hair during it like chunks I had
a bald spot in the back of my head from
stress do you stay friends with the
producers cuz I would imagine you get
close to them you trust them and then
once you watch the show back you're like
oh I don't trust you anymore they're
doing their job and we're just the
suckers on the other end I just feel
like I'm constantly like disappointing
people
Kaitlyn revealed there's also a
therapist on set to help contestants
cope and as for why you never see
anybody actually eating on a date they
feed you before you go on a date so
you're not hungry when you sit down you
know you don't want to watch somebody
talking about their multiple stress and
food free dates aside Kaitlyn says she
has no regrets about doing the show I
obviously like found the love of my life
out of it everything was worth it it's
funny because immediately after the show
you're a little bitter because you just
went through so much but now I'm like
okay I can laugh at ya I'm happy Kaitlyn
and her pick Shawn are now happily
living together in Nashville they're
still engaged but have yet to start
wedding planning we're in Hawaii and
we're like should we just get married I
think at that time bachelors still owned
the rights to our wedding though we
aren't in any rush we're more excited to
have babies than we are to like you know
sign a piece of paper um but at the same
time like uh I can't wait to marry him
as for her ex Nick viols current season
The Bachelor well she's not watching but
she has heard all about bad girl Corrine
who's stupid now
if that's who she is then all the power
to her I don't think she really cares
what people thinking I like it
well Kaitlyn says she doesn't care to
have a nine-to-five job is just too hard
after the Bachelorette so she is writing
music and said she's gonna be starting a
podcast soon
[Music]
you